this is a delicate issue in some
respects but in other respects it's not
it's very simple Peter every day now
we're seeing photographs of NFL players
who are engaged in reckless selfish and
stupid behavior and I don't know whether
it's ignorance I don't know whether it's
deliberate I don't know whether it's a
little of both
but every time I see a picture that is
the aftermath of guys going to a
football field somewhere working out in
a way that clearly does not mesh with
the guidelines that people should stay
at home and dr. Anthony fouled she made
it clear yesterday over and over again
there should be national guidelines for
everyone to stay at home beyond that
they got their arms draped all over each
other forget about social distancing
yesterday it was dak Prescott Dez Bryant
and others I can't quite make out who
the others were but it's clearly des and
dak come on guys especially dak Dax got
an obligation as a franchise quarterback
of America's team there are kids out
there that look up to him they're gonna
follow his lead and if they see him
acting like this is no big deal
if they see him completely ignoring the
concept of social distancing and more
accurately physical distancing how in
the hell are we supposed to get people
to do the right thing Peter how are we
supposed to do it I'm ashamed of dak for
doing this and I'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt and assume it was
stupidity but he's got to make this
right and I've been waiting and watching
for some kind of apology or statement of
something from that Prescott saying to
kids out there look I shouldn't have
done this you shouldn't do it
this is an important time lives are at
stake and we're gonna do better moving
forward knowing the Dallas Cowboys even
if there is a strained relationship
right now between dak Prescott and the
people who sign his paycheck or signed
his paycheck he will hear it from
somebody in the organization I'm sure if
not his agents that you're gonna need to
put out a statement you're gonna need to
say something about this the one thing
the Dallas Cowboys have always done
right is you know the right thing in
terms of what you do in public
okay and that is what I would anticipate
happening at some point today because
you're absolutely right Mike dak
Prescott is a good human being he's a
good person but this is beyond tone-deaf
you know you can't be touching other
people publicly at this point in time
yeah I mean look this is the opportunity
of our lifetimes to use our platforms
whatever they may be however large they
may be to influence others and we can
either seize that opportunity and
influence others in a positive way or we
can engage in reckless and foolish
behaviors that send a horrible message
to people out there who still are on the
fence and there are still plenty of
people who are on the fence we see the
videos of guys playing basketball people
playing soccer there are a lot of people
who are just going about their lives and
it's still happening even a month into
this crisis so here's hoping that we
hear something from the Cowboy's DAC or
both acknowledging that what happened
yesterday shouldn't have happened and
Peter I've asked the league about this
because I think this is going to be a
trend I think we're gonna see more and
more players getting together to get out
onto a football field especially players
who are just getting to know each other
like for example Tom Brady and his new
Tampa Bay teammates and they're gonna be
out there engaging in unsafe behaviors
posing for photos and the league at some
point needs to drop the hammer I've
looked at the personal conduct policy
and I don't want to be mr. Hall monitor
here but again this is the challenge of
our lifetimes and lives are at stake
if the NFL is gonna chase guys around
over things far less trivial than
preventing the spread of a virus that is
killing people by the thousands
worldwide if the league isn't gonna use
a personal conduct policy to tell its
players
thou shalt not engage in these behaviors
that number one are inherently unsafe
number two spread the virus number three
send a reckless message to kids out
there who see these photos and hear
about these workouts if the league isn't
going to use the personal conduct policy
for that why the hell do they even have
the thing Mike and and I'll take this
one step further here's one of the ways
that this whole kind of haphazard
slapdash see sets of policies around
United States really could have an
impact on this and I mean a negative
impact you know one of the very few
states that hasn't ordered people as a
state to stay home is Missouri so you
say well what about the Kansas City
Chiefs
well Andy Reed is being a good soldier
he's doing all his work from home Brett
Veatch the general manager the Chiefs
doing his work from home the mayor of
Kansas City has basically said I want
everybody in the city to stay in you
know this is my civic order but what
happens if you're a player on the Kansas
City Chiefs and what happens if you
drive 20 minutes outside of town where
you're outside of Kansas City and you
can go work out with 8 or 10 fellows you
know of your peers with the Chiefs if
you so chose and I'm not saying anybody
is or anybody will but when you have all
these policies that are not singular
policies I think it leads to these
things you know this the state doesn't
have a policy the city has a policy if
if the if the team that is in that city
wants to not violate the policy players
could go out three or four towns over
and have a workout and not be in
violation of anything it's all this
haphazard thing and I think the sooner
we basically say everybody basically
even though it's gonna kill the economy
everybody's just got to stay home for
the next two or three weeks other than
to go to the grocery store eat to walk
the dog that is it and until we do that
I think we're gonna have these these
little outbreaks in all of these little
places in the country and Peter I'll
take it a step farther and look this is
not political by any means Democrat
Republican I don't care I want people to
be safe I want this pandemic to be
contained to the extent that we cannot
trust our public institutions to handle
this properly it becomes even more
incumbent on our private institutions to
do so in to the extent that the National
Football League is one of the most
prominent private institutions in our
country if not our world and it
aspires to be one of the most prominent
private institutions in the entire world
by way of exporting games to other
countries every year there's a greater
obligation for the NFL to stand up and
tell its players what is wrong with the
images that we've seen the last couple
of days starting with Lamar Jackson
Hollywood Brown and Antonio Brown on
Wednesday continuing with dak Prescott
and Dez Bryant on Thursday the NFL needs
to send a strong and clear message to
its players its employees and the public
if the public institutions aren't going
to do it the NFL needs to grab an oar
and start rowing and so far Peter the
NFL has failed in that regard agree
totally this should be a statement
either from Roger Goodell or dr. Allen
sills who directs all you know medical
efforts inside the league that should be
a statement issued today saying that our
players should be a beacon for the rest
of the country and Mike you're
absolutely right what you said about
about dak Prescott what possibly would
keep a high school quarterback in the
state of Texas who idolizes the Dallas
Cowboys what possibly would keep him
from calling up eight of his friends
after their whatever virtual classes
they have to take today and going out to
the high school field throwing the ball
around or playing seven on seven nothing
that's why it's important to stand up
right now and to be counted
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports